for more than 10 years Jordan
vandersloot the prime suspect in the
2005 unsolved disappearance of Natalie
Holloway has been at this high security
prison in Lima Peru serving a 28-year
sentence for the 2010 murder of 21 year
old Stephanie Flores but now vandersloot
faces temporary extradition to the U.S
on charges related to Holloway's
Disappearance in 2010 vandersloot was
indicted in Alabama on extortion and
wire fraud charges after prosecutors say
he tried to force Holloway's family to
pay him 250 thousand dollars for
information about where to find her body
an FBI sting operation revealed he was
paid at least twenty five thousand
dollars before providing bogus
information that same year he pleaded
guilty to killing Flores in his Lima
hotel room